[موسيقى]
اشدها في العاصمه
معارك المتناحرين في السودان تتجدد تتصاعد
الضربات الجويه ومعها القصف المدفعي
المتبادل في الخرطوم وتشهد مناطق عده من
المدينه جولات عنيفه جديده من الاشتباكات
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع بالاسلحه
الثقيله
بعضها دار في احياء جنوب الخرطوم وحول جسر
الحلفايه الرابط بين مدينتي الخرطوم بحري
وام درمان وشهدت بعضها الاخر منطقه شرق
النيل
في مستهل شهره الثاني يستعر القتال اذا
وتستعر معه حرب البيانات
يتهم الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم السريع
بالاعتداء على سفارات دول عربيه بالخرطوم
وعلى صعيد المعارك يقول الجيش انه احباط
محاوله الدعم السريع الاستيلاء على قاعده
جاويه استراتيجيه وسط الخرطوم وانه تصدى
لهجوم اخر على معسكر الكادرو شمالي
الخرطوم بحري
لكن قوات الدعم تعلن من جانبها سيطرتها
على معسكرات للجيش في المنطقه عينها ستسمع
من كل طرف احاديثه عن خسائر كبدها الطرف
الاخر لكن قل ان تستوقف اي منهما التبعات
الانسانيه للمواجهات المسلحه
يكابد الباقون في الخرطوم للعيش في ظل
انهيار الخدمات وتفشي اعمال النهب وانقطاع
امدادات الطاقه والمياه وتناقص المخزونات
الغذائيه
ثم تنحو اليونسوداني اجبروا على ترك
منازلهم منهم من فروا الى دول المجاوره
ومنهم نازحون داخليا كحال هؤلاء الذين
هربوا من معارك الخرطوم الى بورت سودان
لكن معاناتهم هنا تفاقمها موجه حر شديده
ونقص في المياه وغياب ابسط المقومات
الصحيه انه الوجه الاخر لاقتتال يشتد
ويتمدد
بتجلياته القبليه تجده يحتدم هنا في
الجنينه مركز ولايه غربيه دارفور والتي
تبعد عن مدينه الخرطوم 1100 كيلومتر
ويسكنها اكثر من 170 الف نسمه
اسفرت الاشتباكات القبليه في مدينه
الجنينه حتى الان بحسب مصدر مطلع بجمعيه
الهلال الاحمر السوداني عما لا يقل عن 300
قتيل كما خلفت 200 جريه بحسب المصدر نفسه
هذا اخر ما كان يحتاجه ابناء المنطقه التي
تعاني في الاساس صراعا طويلا الامد ليس
القتال هنا بحده ما تشهده الخرطوم وما
حولها غير ان المخاوف من حرب شامله ما
تزال تؤرق السودانيين ومن يهتم لامرهم
وكذلك من يخشون امتداد لهيب القتال الى
خارج الحدود